Howard had a fantastic interview with
Brooke Shields
they talked about her new documentary
it's out on Hulu pretty baby Brooke
Shields
and to help us break it down we have
the producer of said documentary
actors comedian author you guys know her
she's been on air with Howard and now
she's on the Howard Stern wrap-up show
Ali Wentworth welcome to the show hello
everybody what are a couple things that
you guys cut that you you're like damn I
really wish we had more time she has a
story which is incredible where she
dated dode Fayette
and she was in the car with Dodie in
Paris through going through that tunnel
being chased by Paparazzi you know 10
years before lady died wow and to me
that is like oh my God what a ominous
weird
moment and that she told me because we
were walking around Paris together you
know what I mean that didn't that didn't
have to be mine she just was like oh
yeah you know I dated Dodie fight and
I'm like oh my God I need to have a
camera on you 24 7. another thing she
revealed this morning which kind of
hints on the theme of having to protect
herself was how she made the decision
not to really get involved with John F
Kennedy Jr how come that didn't make it
to the doc I think it didn't make it to
the dog because it didn't have an
organic way of being in the dock I mean
you know we could have gone through all
the people she went out with Liam Neeson
you know we could have but but we didn't
wanted to make it about like who did
Brooke date you know it had to be
somebody that somehow the messaging was
on par with what we were trying to say
as well
um but she's got some great stories
about other people she dated and I just
you know I just ran into Rob Lowe here
because he's doing a little tour for his
TV show and Terry really wanted Rob Lowe
and Brooke to get married because they
were both so beautiful
and what happened
um I guess it didn't take I don't think
was I don't think Rob Lowe is really in
a place in his life where he wanted to
get married at that point so well the
other thing is you know again I think
Howard touched upon it a little bit
today the Andre Agassi thing but I don't
think they talked so I'm a big friends
fan and I forgot that Brooke had done
that episode of the Super Bowl and um
she was on there and she kind of played
the crazy woman and she was like licking
Joey tribbiani's fingers right and Andre
like bro they said he broke all like the
good trophies not the bad trophies I
don't know he smashed all of them
Wimbledon all of them because he went
into a jealous rage because the scene
was with Matt LeBlanc that she was a
stalker and you know she had to sort of
play it crazy you know and Brooke is of
amazing comedian like she's just
intuitively funny and so they want her
to kind of kiss his hand and she stuck
his finger in her mouth which you know
as a comedian like yeah that's go far
you know go far big laugh and when she
did Andre had a complete meltdown and
said she had embarrassed him publicly
and smashed all the trophies which by
the way you can't smash your Wimbledon
Trophy and then you know call up
wimbledon.com and be like I need a
replacement yeah it's gone
um and that's an interesting you know to
watch her be sort of under the the or in
the pouch I would say of Terry Shields
and to get out of that she actually had
to just jump into another pouch which
was the Agassi World
um that's clearly somebody that has you
know no sense of their own power and no
sense of their own place and need to go
in an all-consuming kind of bubble which
is what she did yeah in in there she
talks about how um I think this is again
something that really like stuck with me
she said you know we were probably
better off as friends and I wonder how
you go to somebody that you're married
to and have that conversation you know
what we probably shouldn't be married we
should just be friends yeah yeah well
they did it and now she's friendly with
him and his wife and you know it
actually it all turned out for the
better she's with who she should be with
and so same with Andre
foreign